THANK GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY THE
FIRST BILL HEARING ON THE
COMMITTEE OF ARTS AND SPORTS
TOWARD AND MEDIA OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO LEGISLATIVE
SESSIONS CALLED TO ORDER I'M
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE- CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE AND I WELCOME OUR VICE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MISTER
THEIR S. ADDITIONAL BACK TO OUR
RETURN MEMBERS BUT BLOOM MISTER
CHOI DR CHOI THIS. WAS NAZARIAN
OUR NEWEST MIKE FONG- AND SO FOR
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM TODAY IN
ROOM FOUR FOUR FOUR MASTER NOT
REQUIRED BUT ARE ENCOURAGED. IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION HEARD I
ASK YOU THAT YOU APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. AND ASK THAT YOU PLEASE DO
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. FOR
OUR DIAL AND WITNESSES. THE ALSO
BE USING A MODERATE TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS REMEMBER THE PUBLIC. MAN
OUTSIDE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR. YOU MAY ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE DIALING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO IS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION WILL ONLY TAKE
COMMENTS ON THE BILL THAT IS
BEING PRESENTED. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE. BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL.
IF YOU'RE DIALING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE.
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTRACTION. SO THE- WE
HAVE A QUORUM PRESENT SO I'LL
ASK COMMITTEE SECRETARY TO NOW
TAKE. A TENANTS. BOERNER HORVATH
HERE GALLAGHER IS HERE BLOOM
HERE CHOI YEAH FRIEDMAN. MIKE
VON HERE THE SYRIAN. ALL OF. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COOPERATION AND NOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE
ITEM ON CONSENT. THE FINAL AYE
FILE ITEM ONE AB TWO TWO TWENTY
TWO TWENTY SIX CALIFORNIA. SORRY
CALIFORNIA MAINSTREET PROGRAM WE
HAVE I HAVE A RECOMMENDATION OF
DO PASS THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IS THERE A MOTION
TO ADOPT THE CONSENT COUNTY.
OKAY SO WITH THAT COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BOERNER HORVATH HI CALAVERAS
BLOOM. CHOI- FRIEDMAN MIKE VON
BY THE SYRIAN. OKAY WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN. AND WITH THAT
WE'LL GO TO FILE ITEM TO AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE MISTER
BLOOM ARE YOU READY PERCENT.
THIS IS THE CALIFORNIA. SORRY
THIS IS THE CALIFORNIA CONCERT
IN FESTIVAL CROWD SAFETY ACT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU AND
WELCOME TO THE CHAIRMANSHIP
MADAM CHAIR. I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE
WHICH ESTABLISHES A SET OF
MINIMUM CROWD SAFETY STANDARDS
USING CROWDS SCIENCE AND OTHER
BEST PRACTICES TO GUIDE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES WHEN PERMITTING
LARGE OUTDOOR EVENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IN ORDER TO GUARANTEE
THE SAFEST EXPERIENCE POSSIBLE
FOR EVERYONE ATTENDING. OUTDOOR
CONCERTS AND FESTIVALS ARE
WONDERFUL WAY FOR FANS LIKE
MYSELF TO ENJOY LIVE MUSIC IN A
FUN INTERACTIVE AND EXCITING
ATMOSPHERE- NUMEROUS. FESTIVALS
HELD EVERY YEAR OF COURSE AROUND
THE WORLD THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
AND HUNDREDS THAT TAKE PLACE
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MOST OF THESE EVENTS- THANKFULLY
TRANSPIRED WITHOUT INCIDENT
HOWEVER THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER
OF CONCERTS AND FESTIVALS WHERE
DANGEROUS CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE
RESULTED IN SERIOUS INJURY AND
LOSS EVEN LOSS OF LIFE FOR
CONCERT AND FESTIVAL GOERS.
TRANSFORMING WHAT SHOULD BE A
JOYOUS AND MEMORABLE EXPERIENCE
INTO TRAGEDY. MOST CONCERTS AND
FESTIVALS ARE VERY WELL PLANNED
AND EXECUTED AND MOST CONCERT
AND FESTIVAL PROMOTERS AND
OPERATORS WORK IN CONJUNCTION
WITH COUNTY AND LOCAL
AUTHORITIES HOWEVER THE STATE AT
PRESENT DOES NOT. A SET OF
MINIMUM SAFETY STANDARDS IN
PLACE TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
CONCERT THAT IS HELD THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IS AS SAFE AS
POSSIBLE. THE DANGEROUS
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT ON FALL
DURING THESE EVENTS ARE OFTEN
UNPREDICTABLE AND NOT ALL OF
THEM CAN BE PREVENTED BUT THEY
CAN'T BE PLANNED FOR. OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL DECADES CROWD
SCIENCE AND OTHER BEST PRACTICES
HAVE BEEN UTILIZED BY PROMOTERS
ORGANIZERS AND SECURITY EXPERTS
TO. AND FOR THE WORST CASE
SCENARIOS THE APPLICATION OF
CROPSCIENCE AND OTHER BEST
PRACTICES HELP PROMOTERS
ORGANIZED AND PRETTY EXPERTS
BETTER UNDERSTAND AND PLAN FOR
CHANGE. IF YOU'RE- THROUGH MODEL
. METHODS WHICH CAN THEN BE
APPLIED DURING A LIVE EVENT. BY
PUTTING THESE MEASURES IN PLACE
PROMOTERS ORGANIZERS AND
SECURITY EXPERTS CAN ADDRESS
THESE DANGEROUS CIRCUMSTANCES
SAFELY AS THEY DEVELOP AND PUT
IN PLACE PROTOCOLS TO STOP A
CONCERT OR FESTIVAL OF THE
INCIDENT IS DETERMINED TO. AN
IMMEDIATE THREAT TO LIFE FOR ALL
OF. AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE OF
THE SENSIBLE MEASURE THAT SCARE
THE SAFE EXPERTS POPPED. FOR
EVERYONE SENATE THAT'S ADAM. OUT
TO. SEARCH FOR FRAUD. HERE TO IN
SUPPORT OF THE I'M PLEASED TO BE
JOINED BY MARKET. WHO IS HE ON
BEHALF. BACK DIRECT. FOUR TOM
THE ACT A UNIT OF LIVE NATION
AND THAT PER ELECTRON MUSIC.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- HAS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO GET MY NAME IS MARK A
PRAM THE FIRM OF THE PREY AND
MECHANICALLY AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF EIGHT E. N. E. E. G.
REPRESENT WE LIVE IN A AND TO
THE EIGHT. PRODUCT OF A TO STAY
. EIGHT ONE HEADQUARTERED IN LOS
ANGELES THE WORLD LEADING SO
ENTERTAINMENT COMPANY AND HAS
DEVELOPED WORLD CLASS VENUES AS
WELL AS MAJOR SPORTS
ENTERTAINMENT DISTRICTS LIKE
CRYPTO DOT COM ARENA FORMALLY
KNOWN AS STAPLES CENTER. AT LA
LIVE MERCEDES BENZ AT MERCEDES
PLOTS IN BERLIN AND- THE O. TWO
IN LONDON EIJI IS ALSO THE
WORLD'S LARGEST OPERATOR HIGH
PROFILE SPORTING OF THE- PORTS
FRANCHISES INCLUDING LOS ANGELES
KINGS. LOS ANGELES GALAXY AND
ICE BEAR IN BERLIN FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS AGIUS PLAYED A
PIVOTAL ROLE IN TRANSFORMING
SPORTS AND LIVE ENTERTAINMENT.
ANNUALLY A E. G. HOPE MORE THAN
A HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION GAS
PROMOTING MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
SHOWS AND PRESENTS THEM TO THANK
TWO THOUSAND EVENTS AROUND THE
WORLD INCLUDING THE COACHELLA
MUSIC AND ARTS FESTIVAL. WE BEST
BELT DISPLAYED TO ESTABLISH A
UNIFORM BASELINE OF STATEWIDE
MINIMUM CROWD SAFETY STANDARDS
USING CROWDS SCIENCE AND OTHER
SAFETY AND SECURITY BEST
PRACTICES TO GUIDE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES WHEN PERMITTING
LARGE OUTDOOR EVENTS AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY ONE IS THE PRODUCT OF
THAT COOL COLLABORATION AND
WORSE ABOUT TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
NINE WOULD ESTABLISH MINIMUM
CROWD SAFETY STANDARDS FOR LARGE
OUTDOOR EVENT REQUIRE VOCAL A IS
TO A- THE STANDARD. AND WOULD
FIRE UP TO AN EVENT OPERATION
PLANNED BEFORE RECEIVING A
PERMIT TO HOST A LOT OUTDOOR OF
THIS BILL WOULD. A LOCAL A DO
CHAR. B. THE REVIEW AND APPROVAL
OF THAT PLAN WE WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AND HIS
STAFF WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THIS COMMITTEE TO APPROVE AB TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ZACHARY ALPERN AND I'M
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF LIVE
NATION ENTERTAINMENT. ON THE
HEAD OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AT
INSOMNIAC AND WE'RE DIVISION OF
LIVE NATION AND WE'RE ONE OF THE
LARGEST MOST PROLIFIC PRODUCERS
OF OUTDOOR LARGE FESTIVALS IN
THE WORLD. IN CALIFORNIA ALONE
WILL BE PRODUCING AT LEAST SIX
OUTDOOR MUSIC FESTIVAL THAT
ATTRACT AS MANY AS A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE PER DAY. IN FACT
NEXT MONTH IN LAS VEGAS WILL BE
PRODUCING THE LARGEST MUSIC
EVENT IN ALL OF NORTH AMERICA
WITH THE DAILY ATTENDANCE ADULT
SEAT OVER A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE. IS TO BE. WORK
ASSEMBLY TWO SIX EIGHT ONE. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM FOR REACHING OUT TO
US ALONG WITH FIJI. TO DISCUSS
BEST PRACTICES THAT APPLIES TO A
LARGE OUTDOOR MUSIC FESTIVALS.
NO CROWD SAFETY IS THE SINGLE
MOST IMPORTANT ELEMENT WHEN
PLANNING FOR A FESTIVAL AND WE
TAKE THESE STEPS AS SOME
EXAMPLES OF WHAT WE DO TO PLAN
FOR AN EVENT. WE'LL START BY
CREATING AN EVENT OPERATIONS
PLANNER E. O. P. I WILL DO THIS
IN CONJUNCTION WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THEFIRE
DEPARTMENT. AS WE WORK THROUGH
THE PLANNING PROCESS WILL BE A
VENUE ASSESSMENT TO DETERMINE
WHAT THE POTENTIAL CAPACITY IS
FOR THE SPACE. AND THEN WILL
CREATE A SITEMAP WHICH IS DONE
TO SCALE AND WHAT WE CALL A CAD
AND THIS WILL GIVE US AN
ACCURATE VISUAL REPRESENTATION
OF THE ENTIRE FESTIVAL SPACE.
EVEN DOWN TO THE EXACT SQUARE
FOOTAGE OF THE STAGING AREA EVEN
CIRCULATION PATHWAYS MEANT TO
SHOW HOW PEOPLE MOVE THROUGHOUT
THE FESTIVAL GROUNDS. WILL CHAU
EXACTLY WHO WILL COME IN EVERY
EVENT WE HAVE WILL HAVE LICENSED
PHYSICIANS LICENSE OUR ENDS EMTS
AND PARAMEDICS. THE AMOUNT OF
WHICH ARE DETERMINED BASED ON
THE SIZE OF THE EVENT. AS FOR
THE SECURITY WE WORK IN
CONJUNCTION WITH WHAT IS DEFINED
BY LOCAL REGULATION LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON WATER RATIO IS
PER PERSON. AND THAT IS WITH THE
DEPLOYMENT HAS FOR SECURITY.
WILL ALSO HAVE EMERGENCY ACTION
PLANS ARE EA PEAS. WHICH ARE
DESIGNED TO HAVE STEPS AND
PROCEDURES BASED ON A WIDE
VARIETY OF SCENARIOS THAT CAN
TAKE PLACE RUN EVENT. AND WHAT
WE'LL HAVE IS THAT EVERY EVENT
HAS A COMMAND POST AND THAT'S
STAFFED WITH SENIOR DECISION
MAKING. STAKEHOLDERS FROM ALL
LOCAL AGENCIES SO THAT WAY IN
THE EVENT OF ONE OF THOSE
SCENARIOS. WE HAVE PEOPLE IN
POSITIONS WOULD MAKE
INSTANTANEOUS DECISIONS TO
ADDRESS THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES. SO
WE TAKE THOSE STEPS AND OTHERS
TO ENSURE. ATTENDEES SAFETY ALL
OF OUR EVENTS. WE'RE PLEASED TO
BE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE HAVE NO REGISTER
WITNESSES. SALFORD UGH NOW GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. IF
ANYBODY'S IN THE ROOM. WHO HAS
THAT WANTS TO REGISTER SUPPORT
FOR A- BI. TWENTY TWO NOW. WHICH
ONE OF TWENTY. TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
ONE SORRY I HAVE TO TAKE OFF THE
BUSES. TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE.
PLEASE UP. FOR FUN. ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY SO WILL NOT NOW
GO TO THE MODERATOR MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
. TO SPEAK ON AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I'M SURE
THERE'S NO ONE COMING UP AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. WITHOUT WILL
COME BACK TO THE ROOM ARE THERE
ANY COMMENTS OR- SOME QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. OKAY WITH
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR
CHOI SECOND BY VALLADARES- I
HAVE A QUESTION MISTER BLOOM IF
IT THAT'S OKAY- I SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND IT'S IMPORTANT UPDATE
THE CROWD SECURITY. TO THE
LATEST STANDARDS AND CROWD
CONTROL BUT I DO HAVE ONE
QUESTION REGARDING THE EXEMPTION
OF STATE AND PERHAPS COUNTY
FAIR'S PARTICULARLY BECAUSE-
THAT'S ONE OF THE PLACES LIVE
MUSIC CONCERTS- WITH LARGE
COUNTS TAKE PLACE OUTSIDE. IN MY
DISTRICT ARE NEAR MY DISTRICT
THE SHOOTING IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DURING A MUSIC CONCERT AT THE
DEL MAR FAIR. THANKFULLY NO ONE
WAS HURT CAN YOU ADDRESS THIS
QUESTION- YES SIR- A COUNTY
FAIRS ARE ALREADY REGULATED TO A
BY SEPARATE TO. OF LAWS IN THE
STATE. AND SO IT WAS FELT THAT
WE MIGHT BE IN CONFLICT WITH-
WITH THOSE REGULATIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION
AND WITH THAT I THINK- DOCTOR
CHOI. YEAH THANK YOU FOR-
PRESENTING THIS BILLI THINK
THAT THIS IS A VERY TIME THE
AND- AS WE SEE. SOME UNFORTUNATE
INSTANCES TO DO OUR APPAN SO
WITH THIS ADOPTION OF A MINIMUM
SAFETY STANDARD- I KNOW IF. AN
EVENT IS SET IN PLACE- IN A
JURISPRUDENTIAL OF A CITY OR
COUNTY THAT THE LOCAL- AUTHORITY
. WHAT DO YOU CALL. ALL THE
SAFETY MEASURES. ALONG WITH THE-
A SPONSOR OF THE EVENT HOW- WITH
THIS ZERO IMPROVE WHAT OF WHAT
THE EXISTING ONE MINUTE MAYBE
LIVE NATION- WHAT. ARE THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF CAN. COMPARE
THE EXISTING ONES AND HOW THAT
WOULD BE HOW WITH THIS BILL
WOULD BE FURTHER IMPROVED WHAT
WAS LACKING- FOR THE INSTANCE OF
THAT UNFORTUNATE INSTANCES THAT
THAT TOOK PLACE. SO WILL THIS BE
ANOTHER- WE SOLVE THAT PROBLEMS
. WELL WE CAN- AT THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOI WE CAN NEVER. BE CERTAIN IN
ANY BILL WILL RESOLVE- EVERY
POTENTIAL ISSUE- BUT- WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS IT ESSENTIALLY-
MANDATES THAT ANYONE WHO IS
PROMOTING ARE PUTTING ON A AN
OUTDOOR CONCERT AT THE A TYPE
THAT'S BEEN DESCRIBED WILL
ADHERE TO THE BEST PRACTICES
THAT ARE ALREADY IN PLAY WHEN
LIVE NATION ARE A E. G- UP A
PUTS ON AN OUTDOOR. SO DOES THE
X. OF BEST PRACTICES SO THAT
EVERYONE IS REQUIRED TO FOLLOW
CERTAIN A SET A BASELINE
PRACTICES. OKAY IS SO THIS
ASSURING THEM MINIMUM STANDARD
IS- I THINK- BETTER THAN JUST IN
CASE- IF- AND LOCAL AUTHORITY
WHO- WHEN ISA. OVERLOOKS IT THAT
I THINK A DISORDER BE MORE
BACKUP BUT HOW TO SAY. THANK YOU
WELCOME THANK YOU AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS FRIEDMAN
IS NOW HAS NOW JOINED US MISTER
BLUE MUCH LIKE CLOSE THANK YOU
LIKE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THE SET OF HER AND
SINCE BILL AND I WANT TO THANK-
LIVE NATION AND AEG. FOR
ANSWERING MY CALL AND- WORKING
COLLABORATIVE WITH WITH ME AND-
AND- MY STAFF TO DEVELOP. A OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION IS THAT SELDOM MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE BLOOM.
I KERN RIVER VALLEY OFFICE HIS
MEAT BOERNER HORVATH I.
CALAVERAS GALLAGHER IS I BLOOM
AYE BLOOM CHOI. CHOI I MIKE FONG
HI MIKE VON I FREE. FRIEDMAN AYE
NAZARIAN. OKAY SET UP. THAT BILL
NOW EVENED THE BILL HAS SIX
VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE FOR
MEMBERS THANK YOU AND SORRY FOR
THE PAVEL I A- FASHION. THERE.
YEAH SO THAT'S THE BILL IS OUT
WITH SIX VOTES YEAH BECAUSE I
WORK IN KEEP THE ROLE OF FOR
ABSENT REALLY A ROOM ON THE FIVE
ON THREE AB SEVENTEENTH NINE.
THE STATE ATHLETIC COMMISSION
ACT REGULATION OF CONTEST
LICENSE POSITION. THE MOTION IT-
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS MISTER
MATHIS IS HE HERE. MISTER MATHIS
WERE WAITING FOR YOU. FRIEDMAN
SAYS SHE'S READY TO GO YEAH. THE
MISTER ISN'T AS ARIANNA MATH ARE
WELL TO COME THE COMMITTEE ROOM
AND PER IN THE WE FILE ITEM FIVE
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY FOUR FROM
MISTREATMENT OF COLLEGIATE
ATHLETES HIS MISCONDUCT THE
CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS A HIGHER EDUCATION. SECOND
I MUST REMIND YOU MAY GIVE IT
BEGAN THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
CHAIR I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD
WORK OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS ON
THIS BILL AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SIX SIXTY FOUR IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE THAT
TAKES NECESSARY STEPS TO ENSURE
COLLEGE ATHLETIC COACHES DO NOT
JUMP FROM SCHOOL TO SCHOOL WHEN
THE MAN CONVICTED OR FOUND A
CIVIL TO LIABLE OF MISCONDUCT
UNDER THIS BILL A POST SECONDARY
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION SHALL
NOT HIRE A COLLEGIATE ATHLETE
ATHLETICS COACH AND SHALL NOT
ROUTE RENEW THE EMPLOYMENT
CONTRACT OF AN EXISTING COACH
WHO'S BEEN CONVICTED OR FOUND
CIVIL. OF MISCONDUCT RELATING TO
THEIR CURRENT OR ANY PREVIOUS
EMPLOYMENT IN THIS CONTEXT OF
DEFINITION MISCONDUCT MEANS TO
EXT. INAPPROPRIATE OR
COMMUNICATION OF A SEXUAL NATURE
WITH THE STUDENT. JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO AN LA TIMES ARTICLE
TALKED ABOUT AN FBI AGENT WHO
WORKED IN THE VARSITY BLUES
SCANDAL WHO SPOKE ABOUT HOW ONE
OF THE CONVICTED COACHES HAD
FOSTERED A CULTURE OF CORRUPTION
AND GREED AT USC. AND THE AGENT
ALSO SAID THAT THE INVESTIGATION
SHOULD BE A WAKE UP CALL. FOR
COLLEGES TO HAVE SAFEGUARDS TO
DETECT AND PREVENT SUCH
CORRUPTION AND RIGHT NOW UNDER
THE LAW THERE'S NO MAJOR.
REGISTRY OR LIST OF THESE
COACHES AND THEY CAN GO FROM ONE
SCHOOL TO ANOTHER. PRETTY MUCH
WITH IMPUNITY. UP ALSO BEEN
BESIDE IVORY THERE HAVE BEEN
UNFORTUNATE INCIDENCES WERE
COACHES HAVE USED THEIR POSITION
TO SEXUALLY EXPLOIT THEIR
VULNERABLE STUDENTS. THE MESSAGE
THAT WE'RE SENDING WITH THIS
BILL IS AT ALL LEVELS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA REMAIN
EQUALLY ACCESSIBLE AND SAFE FOR
ALL. I WANT TO ALSO JUST CALL
OUT MY LEJI TO ISAAC KING WHO
HIMSELF WAS A STUDENT ATHLETE
WHO CAME UP WITH THE IDEA FOR
THIS BILL BECAUSE HE HAS. YOU
KNOW IN HIS YEARS I'M SEEN
STUDENTS WHO WERE RIPE FOR
EXPLOITATION I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING WORKING ON THIS BILL
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S AS
IMPACTFUL AS POSSIBLE AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION. BUT REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
THINK WE HAVE NO REGISTERED
WITNESSES AS ACCURATE NOT AT THE
SAME TIME PORT. I HAVE NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION WILL GO TO
ANY. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION OKAY WITH THAT
WE'LL GO TO THE MODERATOR
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY FOUR ON THE LINE. WE
SHOULD BE IN FAVOR OR OPPOSITION
OF AB TWO SIX SIX FOUR PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MAN I'M
SURE THERE IS NO ONE QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. GREAT AND I'LL
BRING ABOUT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY
WITHOUT I HAVE A MOTION BY. WAS
MUCH MUCH. MOTION BY VOTERS
SECOND BY PHONE MY FONG- YOU
KNOW I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I THINK
IT'S SUPER IMPORTANT THAT WE-
ADDRESS THE ISSUES WITH OUR
CLOTHES AND I WAS THE ONE THE
REQUEST OF THE AUDIT OF OUR UC'S
FOR THEIR EMISSIONS SCANDAL AND
I THINK THERE'S LOTS OF ASPECTS
THAT CAME OUT OF THE VARSITY
BLUES SCANDAL AND I THINK THIS
IS REALLY IMPORTANT ONE THING
JUST FOR THE HOUR. WELL CROESUS
REGISTRY ALLOWS PEOPLE ADD AND
DOESN'T WANT THEM TO MOVE AROUND
WITH OUR UNIVERSITIES ONE OF THE
PLACES THAT. THOSE COACHES MAY
GO AS A LAST RESORT IS GO BACK
TO HIGH SCHOOL SO ONE OF THE
THINGS MAYBE. AND THIS BILL AND
AS IT MOVES FORWARD OR IN THE
FUTURE. IS TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE PEOPLE
WHO ARE YOU THERE. BRIBING OR
COMMITTING SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
WITH STUDENTS DON'T GO TO OUR
HIGH SCHOOL SO THAT'S JUST A
COMMENT. AND WITH THAT I HAVE A-
RECOMMENDATION OF DO PASS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION. AND WITH THAT
THE COMMITTEES THAT ARE I'M
SORRY WITH THE AUTHOR LIKE TO
CLOSE WILL CONSIST. WITHOUT
COMMITTEE SECRETARY MICHAEL THE
- A. B. TWO C. SIX FOUR FRIEDMAN
DO PASSED TO HIGHER ED
BOERNER HORVATH I.
BOERNER HORVATH I BALLADEERS
VALIDATORS I BLOOM. BLOOM I CHOI
CHOI I MIKE FONG FIVE THANKS
FONG I FRIEDMAN. FRIEDAN I THE
SYRIAN. THE BILL HAS SIX VOTES
IT'S AN OUT OF COMMITTEE RIGHT
WHAT IS CERTAIN IS OUT AND WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
OKAY MASTERSON IS THERE IN ARE
THEIR WAY SO WE'LL WAIT FOR A
MINUTE.
ONE THE QUESTION HAS JOINED US
IN A MINUTE OF THE COMMITTEE AND
WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU CAN COME
AND PRESENT YOUR BELL FILE ITEM
FOR AB EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. A FOR SO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
THIS CRUCIAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND FOR ALL THE
SUPPORT YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF HAS
GIVEN TO MY OFFICE THANK YOU. AB
EIGHTEEN FEET PROHIBITS IT
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITIES FROM
SPONSORING OR INVITING
PROFESSORS FROM UNIVERSITIES
FUNDED BY COUNTRIES THAT THE
INTERNATIONAL COURT OF JUSTICE
HAVE FOUND TO HAVE COMMITTED THE
INTENTIONAL DESTRUCTION OF THE
CULTURAL HERITAGE OF ANOTHER
COUNTRY. THIS BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT PUBLICLY FUNDED
CALIFORNIA MUSEUMS AS WELL FROM
SPONSORING STATE FUNDED ITEMS OR
ARTIFACTS FROM THE SAME
COUNTRIES. FOR GENERATIONS THE
WORLD HAS ACKNOWLEDGED THE L.
OVERT INTENTIONAL DESTRUCTION OF
ANOTHER GROUP'S CULTURAL
HERITAGE YET IT WASN'T UNTIL.
RECENTLY THAT WE HAVE SEEN THE
GENERAL COURT OF JUSTICE WHEN ON
THE DESTRUCTION OF THE CULTURE
OF A NATION STATE. RECENT A
COURT ORDER AGAINST AZERBAIJAN
TO IMMEDIATELY STOP THE
INTENTIONAL DESTRUCTION OF
ARMENIANS CULTURAL HERITAGE
AFTER ARMENIA BUT A CASE TO THE
A. C. A. C. J. WAS EVIDENCED IN
RECENT YEARS. ALTHOUGH THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME THAT THE ICJ
RULED ON CULTURAL HERITAGE THE
PRECEDENT HAS BEEN SET AND WE
CAN FULLY EXPECT MORE COUNTRIES
TO BRING SIMILAR CASES FORWARD.
IN FACT SOME YEARS AGO ISIS-
COMMITTED THE SAME CRIME BUT
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE IT'S NOT A
NATION STATE- NO SUCH ACTION WAS
TAKEN AGAINST THEM. CALIFORNIA
HAS A PLACE ON THE GLOBAL STAGE
TEMPOS COST ON ACTORS THAT ACT
CONTRARY TO OUR VALUES BY
LIMITING THE ACCESS TO OUR-
SOUGHT AFTER CULTURAL SPACES- TO
NOT IMPACT INDEPENDENT ARTISTS
WHO ARE INDEPENDENT OF THE
GOVERNMENT. WE HAVE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS WE HAVE WORKED ON
AMENDMENTS- THAT CLEARLY STATE
THAT THIS PROHIBITION ONLY
APPLIES TO ITEMS OR ARTIFACTS
THAT ARE STATE FUNDED. WITH
THAT- HAPPY TO ASK ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND- RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE NO REGISTERED WITNESSES
AND SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IS THAT
CORRECT YES YES GALGO NOW WE DO
HAVE A SORRY WE DO HAVE A- A
LETTER THAT WE ARE AND WE
SUBMITTED. A TO YOU FROM MICHAEL
GOVE ON FROM LEXMARK BUT I JUST
COUNTY MUSEUM OF ARTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU- WITH THAT WILL GO TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM AS THEIR ANYBODY WANTS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
THE MODERATOR MODERATOR. PLEASE
ANNOUNCE UP PLEASE CALL ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY ONE. PLEASE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION PLEASE. YOU WHICH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I'M
SORRY. MODERATOR THAT'S AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN. GOOD SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. SURE THERE IS
NO ONE SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME.
OKAY WITH THAT WILL GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES ANY
QUESTIONS. FOR COMMENTS AUTHOR.
WITHOUT MISTER IS THERE ANY
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FORA VOTE
THANK YOU MEMBERS I SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND THE AUTHORS ADDRESS THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE OR WILL BE
ADDRESSING THE QUESTIONS I HAVE
ONLY THE OTHER QUESTIONS FOR THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE WHICH
WILL THE BILL NOT. EMOTION MOVED
BY THE- SECONDED FIVE SECONDS BY
BLOOM. AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS
A HIGHER EDUCATION. WITHOUT
COMMITTEE SECRETARY IN MAY YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN AS IRAN DO
PASSED TO HIGHER EDUCATION
BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I BALLADARES.
GALLAGHER AS I FLEW. BLOOM I
CHOI. WHY NOT VOTING MIKE FONG
BUT MIKE FONG I FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I IS AREA HI. NAZARIAN
I'D. THE BILL OUT WITH SIX VOTES
FOR YOU VERY. THE EVENT WITH
THIS MATHIS. THE BILL. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I AM PLEASED TO
RESENT AB SEVENTY SEVEN NINE
YOUR CONSIDERATION THE SIMPLE
MEASURE CODIFIES THE OUTSTANDING
SAFETY MEASURES THAT ARE STATE
ATHLETIC COMMISSION ALREADY
IMPLEMENTS BUT HAS YET TO CODIFY
. I WANT TO THANK THE ATHLETIC
COMMISSION FOR WORKING CLOSELY
WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS MEASURE
AND I AM PLEASED TO REPORT THAT
THEY HAVE NO ISSUE WITH THE BILL
AND PRINT. MEMBERS OF THE AIM OF
THIS BILL IS TO ENSURE THAT THE
SAFETY MEASURES CURRENTLY
PRACTICED BY THE STATE ATHLETIC
COMMISSION. ARE THE FUNDAMENTAL
STANDARD FOR ALL BOXING BOUTS IN
OUR STATE. NOT ONLY WILL THIS
BILL SHOW OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
ATHLETIC COMMISSION STANDARDS
BUT IT WILL PLACE CALIFORNIA AT
THE FOREFRONT OF SAFETY MEASURES
OF THE SPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR LIFE. THANK YOU MISTER
MATHIS AND WE HAVE NO REGISTER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IS THAT CORRECT
CORRECT CORRECT. SO GO TO
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC IN THE ROOM IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
TO AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY NINE.
NOT SAYING NO WITNESSES OVER THE
MODERATOR. SORRY YEAH WE GOT
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY NINE. NAME ORGANIZATION
WHICH PICTURES. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF OPPOSITION
OF AB ONE SEVEN SEVEN NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I'M SURE THERE'S NO
ONE SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU ALL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND EQUIP ANY.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
THE AUTHOR. OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION BY THE THERE IS THE
SECOND BY DOCTOR CHOI- WITH THAT
MISTER MATHIS MICHAEL'S.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A- AND I
HAVE A- OKAY. MEMBERS THIS
MEASURE MAKES SENSE TO ME AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE MISTER MATHIS WILL
CLEAN UP THE MINOR DRAFTING
ISSUES FLAG IN THE ANALYSIS AND
THE NEXT COMMITTEES SO. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS WITHOUT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY NINE
MATHIS DO PASSED TO BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH HI CALAVERAS.
CALAVERAS I BLOOM ARC BLOOM I
CHOI. CHOI I MIKE FONG MIKE HI
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I DOES ERIN.
SYRIAN I'D. MEMBERS THE BILL HAS
SEVEN VOTES IT'S OUT AND WE CAN
THEN HOW DO I KEEP LOOKING THANK
MANAGER.
OKAY STILL AHEAD. SO WE'RE GONNA
CUTE AND WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH-
THE LIST OF BILLS SO THAT THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CAN ADD ON. WITH
THE COULD. THE PROFESSOR. THE
COMPANY. THE PROPOSAL.
OKAY I WHICH WAS. YEAH YEAH FIND
YEAH. YEAH YES THIS IS
DEFINITELY WORTH A. HUNDRED
RIGHT YEAH YEAH YEAH OKAY. AB
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE NINE. FIVE
ZERO I'D THAT SOUND.
AB SIX SIX FOUR IS A- HI IS
THERE AND I AM WAS OUT. ON A TWO
TWO SIX CERVANTES. FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I NAZARIAN. CONSENT
CALENDARS ADOPTED. WITHOUT THE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM
INTERNET MEDIA COMMITTEE IS NOW
COMPLETE AND THE HEARING IS NOW
ADJOURNED. OKAY OKAY. YEAH.